as the days are getting shorter and
colder there's a place you can swing
away those winter Blues that's Topgolf
and joining us now is Lindsey Hoskins
the Topgolf Las Vegas director of
instruction welcome to the show thanks
for having me first off you guys did a
little transformation to a western
Wonderland over there Top Golf what do
you guys have going on yeah so in our
birdie bar on the second floor we have
this Western Wonderland there's hundreds
of thousands of Lights in there it's
beautiful it's a little different twist
though since the rodeo is in town you
know you're going to see the Western
theme for the holidays I love it I love
it it's so much fun over there Topgolf
and you guys too you offer instructions
and lessons and that's where you come
into play we do yeah a lot of people
don't know that we offer private lessons
we do group lessons we even have some
holiday specials that's perfect a
stocking stuffer is you have a golfer in
your family you guys have specials as
well yeah so we have a two by two
special right now which that just means
two private lessons and two hours of
Gameplay at Topgolf now Topgolf I mean
whenever knows Top Golf so many people
have been to Topgolf I didn't know this
until earlier the top and Topgolf stands
for what Target oriented practice I had
no idea so it's all about accuracy there
you know you only have 200 yards to the
end of the range but a lot of our games
are more about accuracy and precision
which is hopefully what I'm going to
teach you a couple things I I am not I
am not a golfer and I should be that's
something that you know a lot of people
call off in Las Vegas so many great golf
courses yeah where do you even start
like how was am I cool start with the
fundamentals yeah so grip and set up so
left hands on the top since you're
right-handed left thumb is going to go
right down the middle and then your
right hand you can just put it right
below that left hand wrap all those
fingers around the club even that right
pointer finger there you go and that
thumbs down the middle as well I'll tell
it that was always my mistake this
finger was always down and there'll be
times where I'd swing the club and I
would lose the club yeah I guess that's
embarrassing you want a pretty good grip
but let's say feel like you're holding a
bird you don't want to hold it so tight
that you kill the bird but you don't
want it to fly away
all right and then my swing I'm bringing
it straight back yeah so when you take
it back you're gonna try to keep that
left arm as straight as possible yeah so
that's what a lot of begin beginners do
when they're taking the club back
they're gonna Bend this arm and when
they bend that arm they're not going to
be able to make contact again with the
ground if you keep it straight you're
going to just come right back to where
you start that is perfect and it always
head down how my feet position feet
shoulder shoulder width apart yeah yeah
good good question and then bend from
the waist you're going to flex those
knees just a little bit this is another
really good tip to put weight on the
balls of your feet so slightly forward
on those feet versus the heels that'll
help you just be in that nice athletic
kind of stance like you're gonna run
jump
Lindsay you are amazing and you're
offering lessons there at Topgolf you're
one of the main instructors yes I'm the
director of instruction there I love it
someone's watching right now they want
more information what's the website uh
they can go to
www.topgolf.com
lessons I love it and just like Johnny
Carson we will be right back